[Music]
so
[Music]
square is a rallying point for many of
the happy thousands who come to welcome
peace
[Applause]
today sees the arrival of more than 400
happy jamaicans
they've come to seek work in britain and
are ready and willing to do any kind of
job that will help the motherland along
the road to prosperity
[Music]
everest conquered two unassuming men had
climbed the 29 000 foot monarch of the
himalayas
now in the state coach of nepal hillary
and tensing with colonel hunt and others
of the expedition rode in triumph
through kathmandu
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the promised land
martin luther king was shot and was
killed tonight
[Music]
[Music]
next
[Music]
i know full well the responsibilities
that await me as i enter the door of
number 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some of the most vicious hand-to-hand
fighting of the entire minus dispute
the strikers saw it all as a frustrated
act of defiance
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
the plane has crashed into the world
trade center
[Music]
breaking news we're getting from the pa
newswire that there's been reports of an
explosion outside liverpool street
station
[Music]
yes
[Music]
out of many we are one
that while we breathe we hope and where
we are met with cynicism and doubt and
those who tell us that we can't we will
respond with that timeless creed that
sums up the spirit of a people
yes we can
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we are going to make america great again
[Music]
from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home
[Music]
[Music]
you